toby one has been called the voice of
dota 2 he's one of the most well known
and well respected broadcast talents in
professional competitive gaming today
he's also one hell of a karaoke singer
let's get down to business
two two feet hello there I'm calling for
the score eSports and today we're taking
a look rather a listen and the best of
Toby Dawson aka Toby one now I know you
guys know Toby one primarily for dota
but he actually got his start in the
Australian Call of Duty scene
he's also dabbled in csgo and done pub G
hosting and commentary as well now
before we get into those games guys I am
going to give you what you came for
those iconic dota 2 toby one calls
they're all together PB d he comes the i
floss
VP they need this they need the egg is
as follows - cheese if they could have
any chance against lfy being - rack down
against him and I look for the rolling
ball
they said that night we want to keep
running
put it down but early take the agency
model baby TP heart
that's gonna find its lobster once more
super the netherworld
that he drank the life back out of
and now they tougher to find the ice
block is really good for me
gonna be enough sir [ __ ] me
so when he gets out of that
to the trees yet his bTW the bumble the
crows by MTV with
Apple Google get the freezing and here
we go uh-huh game is on the bay is lane
there's a small blood patch were Admiral
bullet trap and it is it is actually
trapped because they came to check for
it now the Sun because I don't know
they're gonna bring it down oh boy James
now will the beam is this weeds may pull
something out of the bag and feet is
gonna go down as well Oh
tidehunter wanna stop what a strategy
coming out from a tunnel MV the Prophet
Bay he doesn't look any cold anything
spice to his siding to Russia it's a
pure fate he spent all his gold on
standing on him and you know try to just
come right out get to kill front of the
bat no one has ever done that know what
it has done in the history of dota
DDC summed up Sylar he said it's going
for kills the back inside the defaulter
cause they have to go back
Alliance will take the win here water
iboga in through the rear that's just
not enough deeps Sadler he tried he
tried for a ball
[Music]
we will be going to three games
sing-sing to light it up with an EMP and
a deafening plus the control is just two
months coming out of Empire has more
locked Envy he gets beaten down this
third point having money if you can't
even use it and resolutions right behind
Phone 7 and when we currently got up
we've got a phantom strike currently up
for Rubik so he's a quick jump in with a
killing off Roshan down a halflife
incomes tongfu now hold on oh yes there
we go fine RV is locked wards to go down
the prep is there and Navi puppy love to
sit around for the biggest leg of his
like 1 second 0 second now I like oh
what a wall back here in October there
was three that was bomb in the disaster
they've lost five Nobby he couldn't feel
amazing but some food but what a play by
line of heaven and Pompey he knows he
can get away with hood and now boy
he got snaking this could be big this
could be really big the arrow from chuan
is able to connect this wall they need
Naga down to throw five I corner no
matter as well they force of secondary
timer price spy cameras whole gym thanks
that means his overall name for a guy at
guys live from Korra in the Lord
keep it rolling this is not something
they want to lose so they get a pole man
Super Cup miracle just used his head
this feels so much my fate booty feels a
church nailing it's a miracle they're
not committing to heavily with a
venomous memory rule as that BKB to
react strikes was all about miracle the
bars are - taka he'll connect follow up
in Japan
the county back talk
like what they have to get down
look in the finder for the better
beaver
baby
and on Stiles Thursday wedding into
puppets gonna TP the sprout will come
control the teamliquid really to speak
over the beefy get to the cream he was
going up to the cocktail observer would
be placed down quick d water to D water
but he would it's dishonest he'll miss
the fight back up caught on fire back is
here for honor on the front lines with
the answers brain launching off with the
manna stopped another stun finally saw
Donna maybe he can bring down Randy's
yes he can that triple kill sir but up
with cheese I keep he wants to keep
going all the pullback in the
coming down
[Music]
we've got a ball take out the whole cake
caboodle
now I can't be the only guy who got
goosebumps from hearing those calls
again can i those are the ICONic serious
kobe-wan dota 2 calls but we be doing
the man a disservice if we didn't
acknowledge his more Mimi Pookie
wacky side and that's what this next
section is all about don't let them in
don't let them see be the good boy
you always have to be conceal don't feel
don't let them know
oh well now they know
oh let it go let it go can't hold it
back anymore let it go let it go turn
away and slam the door I don't care what
they're going to say an RG stood their
ground as that [ __ ] my god
Oh
[Music]
Oh
there is no coming back from this even
the wallplate comment from Tim's IR
that's only an allied we can see that
[ __ ] yeah yeah there is no way they can
win this now even with a second like ah
keys to the two ravages Ohio tube above
the ravaged but MV just freaking
evaporated look at the damage output
money hit on the world highway lose its
life they're running away and bees up in
three seconds begins the front lights
triggers oh wait our burgers they've got
the jab why are you [ __ ] darling okay
you're killing him don't you come he's
got very stepped up there go your gay
fancy the pocket maybe a packing what
hello my name is Tobin so we want
[Music]
would you like a daughter
I can eat 9000 of these all the 9000 my
mama always said life was like a box and
daughter kid never know when you're
going to get hook cuz I realized to put
you on the spot but they did have a
overtip killer that make it kick in just
can we do the dirt hammer X X number X
it's a disaster
thank you so much I'm going to put that
on my facebook page
don't eat me becoming SD three
generations blinks out the boys the
attack and now as the mail was on the
run door
they should smell the wrinkles of cool
adam-16 time as well so he turns around
is he going back into this one makes a
break for the tree let me go and never
quote the tree line people finally fall
down but he don't regard
they've even please in he was together
she has no old team he knows he turns
into a pig lady
in
boys the bar
I've never seen a pig fly until that
point for the RP oh I sigh sigh sexy
sexy sexy they've had enough fun for now
my control I try and find some more fun
like it will realize that we [ __ ] up
and welcome back once again to the PC
health of cheese Invitational I am for
sore thumb with me once again
now guys this video would not be
complete if we didn't acknowledge the
other games that Toby Wong has left his
mark on
he's not just dota2 after all as I said
in the intro he's done caught he's done
csgo and he's done pub G as well and in
true Toby Wan fashion he's left us with
some hilarious one-liners from each one
of those forest lumps off the last one
and snacks are basically replaced with
your testicles burger night come feast
that one back fine but in doing so let's
see what they can do is move not me I
think say nude nicely gonna do it no
restart we're not live yet just where we
thought oh are we gonna go in are we
have actually have a very pass you get
me all excited for nothing boss
seriously it's like geez are my pants
for absolutely nothing but up we will
have the restart alright guys that's all
we got for you this week what was your
favourite Toby one call or moment and is
there a player a topic or team you want
to see us cover in a future video if so
let me know in the comments below and I
will see you next
thanks for watching if you want more
great content just like this be sure to
hit the subscribe button
[Music]